But we,
we have got to prepare ourselves now to be
ready, because if you're ready now, the problems go away.
They think your sheep. I mean,
I asked you on a podcast with you via last time. Where's the line?
What line do you have as an individual that you say
I won't cross? Well, I won't go there. I mean,
if I said to you last summer, yeah.
They're going to tell us that we can't have Thanksgiving with our family,
that we have to wear a mask all the time and the president's going to make that
mandate and they're going to shut down the economy. You and I,
and everybody else would have said never, never.
[Inaudible].
And it's interesting. I, I often think now,
now that I've been taking some of these positions that aren't thought of as
popular or, or okayed by mainstream or whatever,
that the only thing to fear is fear itself.
And I've been thinking about that a lot lately, that the more that I say,
the things that I believe to be true,
that happened to be against the mainstream things. The more I get over that,
because if you can get over the fear,
then if it's true that were on a list and they're coming for us,
then we're on a list. And by the way, pretty much everyone's on the list.
And that's why there's that famous thing. You know,
they came for the Jews first. It's like, we're all,
we're all part of this thing,
but it's a very strange time that you can show me some of these things,
founding documents from the United States documents about saving Jews
during world war two. And it feels like something that's kind of now.
Only if people don't find their courage. Yeah.
I truly believe, and this is why I think you're so powerful.
Courage is contagious. It is people not. Everybody's a leader.
Not everybody's willing to step out into danger, you know,
uh, not everybody's willing to lose all their friends or to whatever,
but when they see someone risk everything and they
see them on a list, if you can get them early enough,
they'll step out. But the longer you wait,
the worse it gets that's Bonhoeffer was, uh,
a pacifist was involved in [inaudible], uh, CU
how he's a pacifist. He, he said, there's nothing else we can do at this point, because it's too late. The
people's
hearts had turned to stone and you couldn't turn them. We have to find a way to make sure that our hearts and the hearts of everybody, we know stay soft and see people as people, not
enemy.
You know, when I was on tour with Jordan,
one of the things that he would bring up often,
because he would talk about the parallels to Nazi-ism to some of the
authoritarian movements of the day. And he would say to everyone in the crowd,
he'd say, you know, there's 3000 of you sitting out here right now.
And I guarantee you that every single one of you would think that you wouldn't
be a Nazi. If this was 1936 Germany.
And that proves probably that you would be.
And I always thought that that was pretty powerful,
that we all think we would do the unpopular thing.
We all think we would do the risky thing.
We all judge everybody by our standards of today.
I'm not sure I'd stand in the end. I mean,
a friend of mine, Marcus Trell, I said to him,
how do you stand torture and not break? And he said, Glen,
everyone breaks. Everyone breaks. He said,
but the ones who break the fastest and the loudest are the ones who will say,
I'm never I'll stand. Oh, I'll stand because they haven't thought about it.
It's why I wanted to bring my kids to Auschwitz. I need you to feel it.
So you can think about it and really look at this as a possibility.
And once you do that and you realize by the grace of God,
I'll stand, um, then you're, then you're ready.
But we,
we have got to prepare ourselves now to be
ready, because if you're ready now, the problems go away.
They think your sheep. I mean,
I asked you on a podcast with you via last time. Where's the line.
What line do you have as an individual that you say
I won't cross? Well, I won't go there. I mean,
if I said to you last summer, yeah.
They're going to tell us that we can't have Thanksgiving with our family,
that we have to wear a mask all the time.
And the president is going to make that mandate and they're going to shut down
the economy. You and I, and everybody else would have said never,
never.
I would've said, you know, maybe they're right about that bad guy. Yeah. Right.
Yeah.
You would have, it's insane to think, look where we are.
And now all of a sudden that's normal. It's the new normal.
Yeah.
They get you with that phrase, the new normal, because there's,
there's an implicit. Oh, except it, it it's implicitly. It's here.
So you better accept it.
The thing about war is war is just about changing
leadership, borders and financial systems.
That's what war is really about for the people up at the top.
And it's usually so horrible that a society
even great ones never go back to the way they were because
you're so willing to accept peace.
I just want to go back to normal that you never reset back to
normal and you'll accept almost anything. Here we are.
Look at what we're willing to accept at this point.
And I know I did when they started talking about the new normal, I was like, no,
no, no, I don't. No, no, no, no. I don't want a new normal. I want normal,
normal.
Normal. We'll be just fine. Yeah.
How many people now would just be happy if we just, if we had, okay,
this is a new normal, and they're going to start, you know, letting,
letting things back up, but it's never going to get the way it was lots.
Lots would get.
Is that why you care so much about history and these things,
because you feel like it kind of grounds you to do the current events that you
gotta do. You gotta wake up every day. You do.
How many hours a day to have talk? Uh, at least at least. I mean,
that's a lot, that's a lot of air time.
I know how much I talk and it ain't five hours a day,
but is that why you care so much about history?
Because otherwise you're just sort of spinning in the, in the morass of the day.
I know clearly what I'm fighting for.
I know clearly what I'm fighting against and my son was
eight maybe.
And he started taking TaeKwonDo and he had to go in to get his first belt.
And I don't know why, but he didn't expect there to be a crowd there.
And, uh, when he was really young crowd,
scared him because of the,
the stuff that has happened to me, that he witnessed as a little kid,
crowd scared him.
And he didn't want to be around crowds and he didn't want to be noticed,
you know? Um, and so we're going, and he's like, no, no, no, there's a crowd.
There's a crowd. And I'm like, Ray, it's going to be fine. It's fine.
It's just the parents. They're just like us. We're just watching your friends.
No, no, no, no. And he really freaked out. So I had to take him home. Well,
the sister got us, got her belt and I'm driving home. And I'm like,
what do I say to him?
And I was quite frankly, it was a little,
but I didn't want to be at him because he wasn't, you know,
he wasn't misbehaving. And, uh,
and we drove home and I held his hand the whole time, but we didn't really talk.
Cause I'm thinking, what do I say, pulled into the house, got into the house.
And I knew exactly what I needed to do. And I said, come into my library,
come on, sit down in the library. And at that time,
my whole walls were covered with artifacts and men determined to be
free and Raul Wallenberg and the picture of the woman that he saved and a
picture of him, all of, all of the heroes, Rosa parks,
everybody Winston Churchill. And we sat there on the couch. I said,
just want you to look at the walls. And he did. And I said,
why do you think I have them up here? And he said,
because they're all heroes and they weren't afraid. And they do the thing.
And I said, no,
because I know each and every one of them was terrified of
doing what they knew they had to do. They were terrified,
but they did it.
That's the lesson of history.
They're just like you, Abraham Lincoln was not a big, tall statue.
He knew he was going to die. He knew it.
He did it anyway. He didn't want to, nobody. Nobody wants to.
Do you think Gandhi? Well, Gandhi may have, because he was doing the hungry,
but that was against his people. His own followers. Yeah. Was like, you want,
you want to be full of anger and rage. I'm not with you.
And until my followers stop acting that way,
I'll starve myself to death. I mean, these, these people were amazing,
but all of them,
all of them had a change of heart and didn't want to do it. Um,
Bonhoeffer went, he was here in America. He escaped Germany.
And he went back to, he came here to America.
He was in New York and he was so guilt-ridden that he left his people in
this dark hour that he went back.
I think it was on one of the last boats that went back and you could get back
into Germany. He went back and he said to all of his pupils,
okay. Let's say you're an atheist. Let's say you're an atheist.
So you really believe that.
But you don't have any other choice than to take somebody's life.
They didn't realize at the time the example,
he was trying to get them to convince him that there's no way you
could do that. Or to accept, convince him that. Yes, I can do that.
He he's involved with Von Stauffenberg.
He's taken to a concentration camp in the end.
He's in a cell with a guy who took the Jews up into airplanes
until their heads popped. He took the, he took people in,
covered them in ice and freezing in the cold water and all of that stuff in
every hospital, in the world, that book from the Nazis,
all of those stats are in every hospital in the world.
And that's why he was sent to a concentration camp because Hitler,
he, he released all this information and Hitler said,
what the hell are you doing? And he said,
you know how many lives will be saved by this information? He said,
we're saving German lives. Not everybody's life.
He a prostitute,
double agent and Dietrich Bonhoeffer were in the same cell.
They were all executed four days before Hitler died.
The guy at the gallows remembers Bonhoeffer because he thanked him.
He walked up the stairs, he got there and the executioner kind of held,
you know, helped him up and then put the noose around his neck.
And Bonhoeffer looked at him and said, thank you for your kindness,
good guns. That's the person I want to be.
But not a person.
You just become. That's a person you work hard to become.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling, check out our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlist, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.